Yes,
very interested in your comments on this
fridge.
Western is committing suicide.
Why is that happening?
Yes.
What do it badly?
No,
there's lots for people to be guilty
about.
You know,
I mean you might say,
to what degree should you bear the
horrendous guilt of your ancestors?
And that's a.
that's a really hard question.
I mean,
because of the radical left answer would
be to the degree that you're privileged
by your ancestry,
you should bear their guilt.
Well,
well,
yes.
The question is then what do you do?
Well,
what you should do is,
what I suggested today I would say is
take responsibility for your lives and
understand that what you have came at a
terrible cost and that you have an
ethical obligation to use it properly
and that would be sufficient to pay for
the sins of your ancestors,
so to speak.
I think it's absolutely reprehensible
that the radical left there's to
attribute to to ethnically identified
groups,
collective guilt.
There's absolutely no excuse for that.
It's completely murderous and that
should be rejected out of hand.
So,
but that's independent of the issue
about what you should do.
Given that part of your wealth is a
consequence of historical catastrophe,
so you should try to sort that out
roughly speaking and for everyone's
benefit,
but not necessarily because you're any
more guilty.
Personally.
You're guilty as hell personally,
but so is everyone else.